be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so what I want to
do here is have a discussion on the idea
of what it means when a mutant is
referred to as beyond
omega-level as well as how this
information translates to the character
of Gabriel summers and the steps that
Marvel took to demonstrate him as being
one of the most powerful characters in
all of Marvel Comics
so in my video on mutant power classes
we had talked about how within the
context of Marvel Comics the x-men the
various governments and races of the
Marvel Universe all structure the mutant
hierarchy in terms of most powerful -
least powerful near the top of the
Pantheon rests around nine individuals
all of which are considered to be the
most formidable threats on earth
possessing abilities like element
manipulation in the instance of storm or
the power to control the genetic
structure of others in the case of
elixir these nine individuals represent
mutants with powers that have no clear
limit and no end to their potential
beyond this risk characters who are
referred to as existing beyond
omega-level mutant these five characters
are individuals whose powers transcend
measurement and allow them to control
one or all aspects of reality itself
thereby removing them from the confines
of earthbound threats and making them
Universal or in the case of Mad Jim
Gaspar's multi Universal threats as an
example in Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four during his battle with
the mad Celestials from another reality
both a present and future version of
Franklin Richards were described as
beyond omega-level meaning that his
power placed him on par with the cosmic
entities of not just his own universe
but any universe in the Marvel
multiverse and x-men the 198 a companion
comic focusing on the fallout of the
House of M and the D powering of 90% of
Earth's mutant population a man named
Absalom Mercator was revealed to exist
beyond Omega level and had the power to
manipulate matter on a subatomic scale
whether by direct or indirect contact
while these two individuals highlight
the extreme power available to beyond
omega-level mutant Vulcan represents a
more reasonable approach and that while
he is beyond Omega level this isn't
necessarily due to his ability to skew
reality so much as control over the
fundamental energies that make up the
universe
so Vulcan makes his debut in the 2006
story deadly Genesis which served as a
read con taking place between the time
at the original x-men series ended and
the time it was relaunched with
giant-size x-men issue number one and
1975 with giant-size x-men Marvel had
established that the original five x-men
were taken by living Island called
krakoa and that their rescue required
Xavier to create a new x-men team
consisting of storm Colossus Wolverine
Nightcrawler and others what Ed Brubaker
did with daily Genesis was introduce a
story with a team that made up
giant-size x-men issue number one was
actually Xavier second attempt to rescue
the original x-men and that his first
attempt came in the form of Gabriel the
third Sommers brother Darwyn
a mutant who could adapt his body to any
situation sway a mutant who could
control time within a short distance of
her body and Petra a tear a kinetic who
had limited control over the ground by
causing minor earthquakes and creating
rock formations now as he's presented
here
Vulcan Zordon story comes directly out
of the origin for Scott Summers and his
brother Alex Summers when Scott and Alex
along with their father Christopher and
mother Catherine encountered the Shiar
empire and akin at the time while Scott
and Alex were sent to safety using a
parachute Catherine was two months
pregnant with Gabriel when she and
Christopher were taken aboard to kinship
while Christopher tried to fight back to
free themselves in the end he was
subdued Catherine was killed and Gabriel
was taken from her womb all while
Christopher was made to watch now with a
history of Christopher saw him sent to a
prison planet to work as a slave the
story of Gabriel saw him place in a
Shiar growth chamber allowing him to age
into a young man at an extremely fast
pace following this Gabriel's memories
are given in bits and pieces since he
doesn't remember everything about his
past as he tells us after being
artificially aged Gabriel was sent to
work as a servant for a wealthy family
in the Shiar Empire during his time
there he was refriended by an old woman
named AI Andrew who gave Gabriel a book
on ancient Roman mythology which also
includes the coming of Christianity and
Roman society and by extension the
introduction of Gabriel as one of the
Archangels of God in addition to this at
some point during his adolescence
presumably during his puberty
Gabriel's powers manifested which
normally happens there
this time in a mutants life unable to
control it and with no one to teach him
how to use his powers Gabriel
accidentally killed Diane Jewell by
disintegrating her now between the time
of die and roll's death on the Shiar
homeworld and Gabriel's recruitment by
Xavier not much is given at some point
Gabriel revolted against the Shiar
guards who have been keeping him as a
slave for the wealthy family destroying
them and fleeing the Shiar homeworld
Gabriel found himself in a sewer in New
York City presumably living with or near
the Morlocks and was rescued by more
McTaggart a friend of Charles Xavier and
mutant researcher who had devoted time
to adopting mutants and introducing them
to the Xavier school wrapping back
around to Gabriel's recruitment in an
effort to save the five original x-men
while the group was able to free Cyclops
before they could reach any of the other
x-men the island had begun to fight
Gabriel and his team during the conflict
sway was ripped in half and Darwin
Gabriel and Petra were completely
annihilated by an energy attack from
Kurkova nowhere giant-size x-men saw
Cyclops return to croco with storm
Wolverine and the rest at the end of
that story
Jean Grey had sent the island of Ko Cola
into space what Ed Brubaker did was take
this idea incorporated into deadly
Genesis and tell us that while this
happened Gabriel summers in Darwin
remain trapped inside after Petra had
used her dying act to create a cavern
during this time Darwin used his ability
to adapt to any situation and converted
his body to pure energy because Vulcan
had the power to absorb and manipulate
energy darwin worst himself with vulcan
and in doing so allowed the two of them
to stay alive within the island as it
floated in space now where the story of
Vulcan continues on and deadly Genesis
for the purpose of our discussion
regarding his powers deadly Genesis
isn't wildly important but there are a
few things we need to cover from the
story the first is that with deadly
Genesis picking up as part of the
fallout from the House of M which saw
the Scarlet Witch stripping the powers
from 98% of the mutant population with
Xavier missing following the house of M
and the x-men unable to locate him the
control of the Xavier school rests under
the authority of Emma Frost a former
member of the Hellfire Club turned hero
and member of the x-men when Gabriel
woke up and made his return to Earth
while Emma was using cerebro to search
the planet for Xavier by looking for his
meeting signature the computer detected
Vulcan which registered off-the-charts
as a mutant
that existed well beyond omega-level as
it was described by Emma Frost with Emma
established as an omega-level telepath
and uncanny x-men issue number 513 as
the writer for deadly Genesis Ed
Brubaker used this to establish how far
above her Gabriel stood and that when
she attempted to read him her mind was
completely overwhelmed and shut down now
what I also want to touch on here is
Vulcan and is dealing with Rachel
summers as a daughter of Jean Grey and
Scott Summers from the Days of Future
past story Marvel ruled Rachel's
character over into the main timeline
explaining that when Kitty Pryde had
kept Days of Future past from happening
that future became an alternate reality
something Rachel looked to escape from
over the course of her publication
history she served alongside the x-men
became a host for the Phoenix force and
became part of the British superhero
team Excalibur but at the time of this
story she had rejoined the x-men using
the mantle of Marvel Girl out of respect
for Jean Grey who was now deceased when
Vulcan shown up on earth after his
awakening his goal was revenge against
Xavier for the death of his teammates
and sought to lure Xavier out by
kidnapping Cyclops and Marvel girl
believing that she was Jean Grey while
he quickly learned that this was
actually Rachel during the conflict
Vulcan demonstrated his abilities to
control energy by shutting down the
synapses in Rachel's brain and knocking
her out in the process now the reason
why this is important and a huge display
of power is because as a harbinger for
the Phoenix force and an omega-level
telepath Marvel is once again
establishing how powerful Vulcan is and
that neither Emma nor Rachel were able
to stand against him now in terms of a
full-on display of his power as well as
a definitive answer to what it is that
he can do with deadly Genesis serving as
an introduction for Vulcan and a prelude
to the war of Kings the conclusion of
deadly Genesis saw Gabriel making amends
with Xavier and Cyclops but also saw him
learning about his backstory and the
death of Christopher and Catherine at
the hands of the Shiar seeking to gain
revenge with uncanny x-men issue number
477 which covers the time that Vulcan
left Earth and traveled to the Shiar
what we're told is that originally
Vulcan was not an omega-level mutant
instead when the skull at which stripped
98% of mutants of their powers and woke
Vulcan up the energy also enhanced his
powers making him Omega level now why it
wasn't this happen is never truly
explained but I would surmise that this
was Marvel simply providing us
an offhanded explanation of why vulcan
is an omega-level character a sentiment
that's actually compounded on during the
war of kings event proper with Vulcan
learning that the Shiar Empire is now
ruled by de Ken Cicero Alondra Vulcan
arrives at the Shiar homeworld and
splits their society in half causing a
civil war between those who would rather
live as one of Gabriel subjects than die
by his hand at the same time that this
was happening
Marvel was writing a story about the
Inhumans who were looking to escape a
life running from the Kree as they
constantly attempted to use the Inhumans
to their own ends attacking three Shia
our warships and invading the Kree
homeworld of hala Black Bolt took over
the Kree Empire but was targeted by
Vulcan due to his destruction of the
Shiar warships being viewed as an act of
war with his declaration of war
initiating the war of kings event and
guardians of the galaxy issue number
fourteen which served as a tie-in and
also saw the return of Adam warlock a
messiah figure within the Marvel
Universe not unlike Jesus Vulcan was
tracked down by Adam warlock in an
effort to end the war and return peace
to the universe while the battle between
them was short-lived Marvel effectively
gives us a definitive explanation of how
powerful Vulcan is when Adam warlock
states that he had to flee the battle
due to the fact the Vulcan was one of
the most powerful beings he had ever
encountered including the various cosmic
entities what Adam warlock tells us is
that within seconds of their encounter
Vulcan had consumed almost all of his
energies and was actually feeding on the
energy of the universe itself and that
in the end the only thing he could do
was run away what this means is that
while Vulcan does not possess the power
to warp reality and fall short of
characters like Franklin Richards who
could simply will him out of existence
in comparison to beings like Galactus
and the Celestials Vulcan stands as
their equal and is able to rival and
even possibly exceed them and power with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end I hope it shine
some light on how powerful Vulcan is and
where he stands in the pantheon of the
Marvel Universe and I will catch you
guys later peace